it's okay
we must bide our time I hate what the
kids it's okay to say yeah Oh sup
recheck nation I'm Greg ever and I'm
John Humphrey we are gonna watch today a
video from Royce two five nine and
what's my homeboy doing well he is
freestyling right here would Funk Flex
DJ Premier you see at our patreon we
have a lot of goodies actually we do
weekly Q&A s TV show reaction watch
along for many shows that includes
attack on sided Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood my hero academia
supernatural Riverdale in Gotham and
John actually covers quite a few amazing
videos around two to three a week over
there since most of them get blocked
this is gonna be cut up for the youtube
version just as a little heads up that
way it's not blocked and one of our top
water tears with our video you request
and with staff I don't lay put up only
YouTube's and today comes from a
handsome man named George let's get to
it
nothing nothing so I may or may not
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
here we go yeah right now finally we
ship after until the day but I'm finding
the black digit I'm falling I've called
it all kind of pyrotechnical fighters in
the sky with heaven during my final
eclectic spiral to die tree that green I
don't see it I'm color prime with my
iron axes with my mother on the double
line on the axis any other kind of
success is up the crime dominoes with
destiny I'll forever be [ __ ] fried
I'm fine with rose top five but you know
I'm happy at platinum when I was happy
you're back by 500,000 with souls
my promise accomplishment now is when I
got quiet to get sober your silence is
gold
I left my whole story fly no cost to the
people while I'm talking to Joe no but
I'm talking Joe watch from the emus no
just telling me we just wrote something
my demise are supposed to be weeks ago
keep your smoke coming I'm over here
with five when it sounds like this some
[ __ ] you wanna see me going out he's
gonna check the side rings we make paper
you party we play Vegas
Memphis I green surrounded me when we
play pages I'm [ __ ] the picture my
dreams and we made sacred my BMW I dream
like these break things I'll be giving
pictures for the slack they put the
[ __ ] Grandpop trapping this for
rappers I be crying like the dancer I
know I'm a cancer male eating south of
France he who doubts the man
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
with winners
everyone would you dinner [ __ ]
switching quickest brew secrecy Jenna we
give in our turkeys on Thanksgiving like
Nino with us we've been passing our TVs
like Wendy Williams all I know is dead
I'm the wild child no smoke with these
bars
they focus on the common so I'm
attention ropes it down the coast of
Monaco
[ __ ] [ __ ] asleep
ma connect me get you a whole kilo of
coke so he can go geronimo he should
receive
[Laughter]
the DM z-- sharking a deep end put these
pawns on if i soften your defense and
all i see it spread around the streets
today about a freak away from having
Issa Rae he cannot believe some rain in
whoa did you see these great tell them I
said bring his ass better bring his hand
let it sink we'll play we don't care
what you seen hit you in your face with
the butt of the gun you can get your
free credit than few strings pop go the
weasel [ __ ] people either I mean you
got pop culture FIFA [ __ ] all I know
it's big in pop quotes popped open screw
the triggers now I pull the cops over
get him [ __ ] season tickets why he used
to shoot me down fishes now see the
missus she turns you to a family how
quicker than Peter Griffin I'll kill
myself when I was 14 and she - one night
[ __ ] probably got more seeds than Peter
Gunz right with nothing but broth
quarterbacks and uncles Ryan Wright
Tina's y'all [ __ ] is cut like get rich
or die trying' wifebeaters
me I'm just Farm shoulder straps and
muscle if you're a hater let's do it I
whoop your now then I hope on your point
later the Whitman's are going round like
a tornado I do the fluid makeup so many
men shopping in wicked section and ain't
no ladies left you [ __ ] crazy yes you
plan crazy
this is KP prime available 316
there may have been some bars in that
video it's possible Thanks you don't
even hear it and see it bar okay
was he rapping that wasn't Eminem wait
what's happening he insulted all kinds
of people and I mean one of these people
and yet I'm offended all right well you
you were almost one of those people
because there was a little Ryan right in
there so I couldn't catch exactly I'm a
different guy yeah but even still man
lyrics are made to be oh man he's
attacking all kinds of people here Royce
to 5/9 is an amazing amazing lyricist
dude he's a fiery emcee like he's fast
but he's not so fast that you can't make
out what he's saying nah he Ella cute
it's really hard I love how he
especially with a freestyle like he'll
do the thing where it's common in rap or
you I kind of stretch out certain words
or pronounce them a different way in
order to have them rhyme but then he
also knows how to go into like
abbreviations to make them rhyme as well
this guy's vocabulary is gnarly like
like this kind of rapping is to me such
a fascinating art form because
especially for this kind of freestyle
cuz you're insulting you're using a lot
of profanity a lot of vulgarity a lot of
people out name checking folks same time
you got to be on be you got to be a
little bit poetic about what you're
doing yeah you got to have some kind of
meter to your rhymes you gotta have good
rhymes you know I mean and the thing is
he to is is doing these flows that are
so intricate that it becomes a present
because you'll have these patterns that
aren't just AAA BBB you know it'll he'll
jump around between like rhymes with it
yeah you know the bar or whatever and
these guys have things like blow my mind
because I see here going wow you really
came up with all this on the spot like
like none of this was
in your mind already or sure some of
what is or some rhymes maybe some of it
hadn't been put down on paper
specifically but I'm sure a lot of times
to kind of pull from the subconscious
sometimes in those rappers will write
stuff down and then probably forget
about it but it gets stored somewhere in
the noggin so then haste it's like the
way a stand-up uses their notebook to be
like oh the idea all right I know it's
yeah yeah exactly man he's feeding off
of energy here like me I'm just what's
this guy's name flex DJ its Funkmaster
Flex to you buck oh yeah to me I'm just
flex that's who I am well that I love
the way they shot this I love that you
just have flex in the corner every
couple minutes I pick it up in a in a
very low-key kind of way yeah and Royce
I noticed like the first verse he's like
making direct eye contact with the
camera
yeah and then as he keeps going he
eventually starts to close his eyes so
he can just get back to feeling because
they're imagined sees think it like
distracted by everything you know yeah
you got to get back to just the feeling
State and just trust whatever is flowing
out of you at that time it is such a
skill that I feel like even to this day
it's still underrated because what we
primarily look at what someone is
freestyling is their rhymes that's what
we always look at is the rhymes but
there's so much more intricate details
to that than just making sure this
rhymes with this word or at the end of
that you know I'm always impressed if
you're on beat and then you go from one
rhyme to like I don't know if you take a
simple sentence like I was looking the
other day and I saw a cat and then it
looked right back at me it was fat on
some [ __ ] yeah something simple like
that but then when they started like I
was going around the neighborhood and I
saw this little thing I would
to go away that's crazy
yeah there's so many ways to get
creative and to bend the rhyme schemes
around I've seen a lot of freestyles
over time but this was Matt impressive
because it seems like he's firing on
every cylinder it's like he's really
getting into some content with what he's
trying to say off the dome but it's also
really intricate in terms of just how
many words he's using like I've seen
free styles that are not so verbose is
this his vocabulary is very big yeah
that was the thing you mentioned earlier
is like you know he's good at jumping on
the abbreviations or inversely you know
finding ways to warp words to fit the
rhyme scheme or whatever but he's also
just great at throwing in like a giant
$10 word like like vitiligo Wow like
that's mad creative and yeah like his
vocabulary just in general is impressive
well he pulls from everything here he
pulls from TV he pulls from movies he
pulls from the music industry pulls from
the wide variations of the music
industry he pulls from culture social
issues yeah he pulls from so much
throughout here that one line about like
in the streets wherever the odds aren't
even like yeah like there grew so many
great little quotables and like clever
quotables in this he's someone who
should be more famous he is a famous
rapper and I feel like in the mainstream
eyes he tends to be associated with his
bad meets evil duo with Eminem but this
I mean if you should want to know if you
get on poor Roy stew 5 not without
having someone else featured on a track
with him this is pure example because
you could imagine like how great his
actual lyrics are when he's writing it
down with Xhosa just freestyle having
time to pound this is already like a
meaningful freestyle cause a lot of
times you know you hear free styles and
they get kind of redundant it's a lot of
like stunting free styles of
braggadocious free styles or just you
know I feel like yeah a lot of freestyle
I guess that was the difference of this
one I'm like guys making points yeah
yeah yeah well it seems like maybe he's
just done this for long enough that he's
past the point where it's just like okay
gotta just make sure that I come up with
words and rhymes that make sense yeah
now he's to the point where it's like I
was gonna say a bunch of stuff here
yeah you know and to have that level of
skill and proud because you know
freestyling is hard improvisation is
tricky anyway and to do it with such
intricacies as fascinating same go for a
magazine he talked about how he
recovered and he said I didn't know any
that he talked about being a former
alcoholic and he got sober and it's cool
because in between and before you see
just a really calm guy not like a
nervous calm or pretentious calm he just
seems like a natural econ dude yeah just
like fire super fast yeah yeah yeah is
the key being calm or is the key to just
let your thoughts middle ground there
you know is it being common to you
unleash the storm
what is it seems like there's some kind
of storm in there yeah when you go into
sobriety you tend to chill out a lot
more and I could like a really just
chill dude you know face tattoo and
everything lyric cool yeah this is an
awesome video and Stuart George he
himself has a YouTube channel where he
rhymes just as well as Royce does yeah
three styles are really insane you
should check and I found out this guy's
actually from the UK British we got a
lot of UK subscribers and he is one of
them and he said that one of his dreams
one of his goals just a one-day beat in
a real rejects YouTube videos yeah and
to you I say maybe unless you're a hot
girl it's tricky what's the point in
having you here man it's like sure we
got Andrew with his comic book knowledge
and Kyle with his comic book knowledge
but let's face it people mainly come
here once a week look at a hot girl look
at some stuff fortunately you're not a
hot girl you're a hot man and that
doesn't do as well in the view count we
only do things for clicks and views
buddy yeah
there's no quality assurance here it's
mostly just you know I'll tell you what
to get a sex change then we talk I've
been looking to bring on more
transgenders
translucent transfix iation Queer Eye
for the straight guy yeah we should have
guests of all varieties on this channel
any and all types of person can guess if
you're a hot girl it's all it takes or
air about personnel that yeah you don't
really need a personality if you're hot
I don't know personally but you don't
need a personality I don't have a
personality this is also hope this is
just as weird as you wanted it to be
Stewart you guys who subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
bell and sayonara